[Música]
Bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de France 24 hoy no estoy por mi
compañera herminia Fernández sino que
estoy con ella en estudio como
periodista invitada herminia bienvenida
a su programa Hola Paula termina usted
nos trae un reportaje de Venezuela que
es de que desde 2019 comenzó a exportar
grandes cantidades de chatarra luego de
que la administración de Nicolás maduro
reformara y crear a leyes para tener el
control de Este mercado el
desmantelamiento de la industria
petrolera de la siderúrgicas y de obras
en construcción abandonadas sirven ahora
como desechos para vender Y obtener
ingresos de los puertos donde alguna vez
exportaban productos petroquímicos Ahora
salen por partes los recursos y activos
de un país en recesión desde hace una
década tanto el gobierno nacional como
los venezolanos de clase popular se
están beneficiando de la venta de
chatarra que se exporta a varios países
del Mundo principalmente a Turquía que
el último año compró
936,150 toneladas a la nación caribeña
hermi Por qué un país que tiene las
reservas de petróleo más grandes del
mundo ahora está exportando chatarra sí
Paula la crisis económica que ha vivido
el país durante los últimos 8 años llevó
a que no se le hiciera mantenimiento a
las instalaciones petroleras Son miles
de esposos abandonados que ahora están
siendo desfantelados para vender sus
partes como chatarra con el
reconocimiento de las sanciones de
Estados Unidos el gobierno ha buscado
diversas vías de ingresos anteriormente
se vendían desechos en pocas cantidades
pero desde hace cuatro años se comenzó a
impulsar estas exportaciones a través de
privados en el año 2021 la chatarra fue
el quinto producto de exportación de
Venezuela y el número 18 a nivel mundial
en 2020 un año antes Venezuela exportó
71,5 millones de dólares en chatarra
convirtiéndolo en el exportador número
52 de esta materia en el mundo y el
número 7 del producto más exportado en
el país Caribe
Los invito a ver este reportaje
[Música]
la chatarra un producto de exportación
poco tradicional en Venezuela se ha
convertido en una oportunidad de negocio
desde hace cinco años los desperdicios
de materiales ferrosos de un país que
tiene la infraestructura industrial y
petrolera abandonada por la crisis
económica está haciendo una fuente
importante de ingreso para el gobierno y
un modo de subsistencia para muchos
venezolanos en este barrio ubicado en
los suburbios de Maracaibo la capital
del estado zulia al noroeste del país
apenas sale el sol comienza el
movimiento de los llamados chatarreros
Danny ocando es uno de ellos alquila a
diario una bicicleta para la recolección
de materiales metálicos la falta de una
oferta de empleo estable lo obliga a
comprar y vender lo que encuentra para
sobrevivir
chao antes no se recogía lo que se está
recogiendo ahora porque todo tan este
deseando las cosas tan limpiando y lo
que no sirve lo van votando y nosotros
como chatarrero salimos a la calle y lo
conseguimos lo venimos a vender pero
ahora Esto es lo que la mayoría de las
personas de por aquí hacemos
este día después de caminar unas horas
Danny tuvo suerte de encontrar material
que podrá vender
Como cuánto crees que te pagarán por eso
todo depende de lo que lo que pese
porque como es lata entonces la lata la
paga más barata no solo el hambre lo
lleva a trabajar largas jornadas bajo el
sol y con altas temperaturas
también lo hace para reunir 300 dólares
que cuesta una tomografía que necesita
su madre enferma de cáncer
pero hoy no ganó lo suficiente para el
examen médico
la ganancia sólo da para comer
o sea con la 32 bolívares que esté el
material o sea compro un almuerzo o sea
un arroz pollo las verduras
porque como somos mi mamá y yo o sea
rinde pero para una familia completa no
Virginia Marín es la dueña del negocio
que compra la chatarra que recoge daño
este es el oro que puede tener los
pobres ahorita porque ellos tienen mucha
ayuda por esta parte y de sobrevivir de
alimentarse Pues llega mucha gente niños
adultos ancianos
esta mujer lleva 10 años comerciando
desechos metálicos y admite que en los
últimos cinco la venta se ha mantenido
en auge
Yo no sé de dónde emana tanta chatarra
aquí pero sí siempre se consiguen si hay
muchas cosas que ya sea deteriorado pues
cosas de que ya no ya no ya no sirve hay
mucha chatarra de carros Pues que ahora
la gente lo pica y lo viene y lo trae y
lo venden
Aunque parecieron un negocio rentable y
seguro la comerciante se cuida de no
recibir materiales estratégico
denominado así por decreto presidencial
a las tuberías de hierro al bronce a las
guayas y al cableado eléctrico
lo que es penalizado no se recibe
llega uno de los días de cargar el
camión con 30 toneladas de chatarra que
le pagarán a 180 dólares cada uno ya el
cliente está a la espera del material
que venderá entre 3600 dólares la
tonelada Virginia sabe que su mercancía
es codiciada y que se vende fuera del
país
al mes
como 10 gandola Esto va para la parte de
los puertos a veces o la parte de eso la
hoguera y Esto va encaminando para allá
para Japón para las partes de allá de
afuera
ella supone que Japón es el destino
final pero en realidad va a Turquía el
mayor comprador de chatarra mundial el
gobierno venezolano exporta estos
desechos metálicos a través de privados
desde hace cinco años
en 2021 Venezuela ocupó el lugar 18 en
el mundo y el primero en Latinoamérica
en comercializar esta materia prima
según el Instituto oficial de
estadísticas Turco en 2021 ese país de
Europa Oriental compró 430 millones de
dólares a la nación caribeña
[Música]
recolección de el alcalde de Maracaibo
Rafael Ramírez explica de Dónde surge
toda la chatarra que ahora se exporta
hay que ver con el deterioro de algunas
cosas de algunas infraestructuras que
por el que ese deterioro la originó
abandono y al original abandono pues la
gente siente que tiene una oportunidad
para para apropiarse de eso pero aún
cuando es una oportunidad para los
pobres también hay un ganador real en el
negocio
esta tarde no la está moviendo
necesariamente un proceso la estamos
viendo la gente en su forma de
subsistencia Y eso es desde
moverla en bicicleta o porque el que
tiene la posibilidad de movilizar
grandes cantidades de chatarra solo es
el gobierno nacional
Ramírez conoce el procedimiento y sabe
que el puerto del zulia facilita la
salida de estos materiales
todos los que puedan de alguna manera
estar beneficiándose de eso tienen una
permisología nacional que no pasa ni por
el estado Ni por el municipio pero que
hace que su puerto de destino con
nosotros que tenemos un puerto sean
sitios para poder embarcarla y añora los
viejos tiempos cuando por este muelle se
exportaban productos de primera
necesidad
este Puerto movió otras cosas
materiales los productos de exportación
de la ciudad y los que venían de algún
tipo de de otros estados que venían a
sacar su mercancía por allí la chatarra
quinto producto de exportación de
Venezuela surge del desmantelamiento de
equipos en desuso de la estatal pdvsa de
otras empresas siderúrgicas de obras de
construcción paralizadas y de vieja
maquinaria privada
en la costa Oriental del Lago Ricardo
Vargas trabajador de pedevesa desde hace
cuatro décadas muestra los campos
petroleros que están siendo
desmantelados desde que fueron
abandonados hace 10 años la estructura
que mantiene El pozo en pie todo eso lo
desarma en la noche y se la lleva Ok es
más me atrevería a decir que hay parte
que se llegue a contratista y se la
lleva como a la permisología del
gobierno del Estado para chatear esos
materiales
se llama bloque viajero acero
galvanizado y aluminio son los
principales materiales que se extraen de
cerca de 15.000 pozos petroleros que no
tienen mantenimiento Y que forman parte
del material estratégico
si no se hacen inversiones que superen
los 70.000 millones de dólares en los
próximos 10 años Esto no se va a
recuperar
con poco optimismo Vargas opina que el
desmantelamiento progresivo de la
industria petrolera venezolana para ser
vendida como chatarra no acabará
por aquí esto es un de mantenimiento
progresivo por parte de alguno ente del
estado que no les duele este país que
prefieren la chatarra que poner a
producir a los pozos de petróleo
pero el desmontaje de las partes de Los
Pozos también lo hace lampa común y un
grupo de la población en pobreza
aun cuando están en riesgo de pagar
cárcel por adueñarse del material
prohibido de vender
es el caso de este pescador que espera
al caer de la tarde para actuar
[Música]
Aunque desmantelar no es el trabajo
principal de este hombre es un oficio
que hace cuando no tiene dinero
es un acto contrario la ley pero no
quiere morir de hambre
se ha convertido
una salvación para sustentar la comida a
la casa entonces ella burro casero
hoy con los restos de uno de los pozos
que le dio riqueza a Venezuela por 60
años podrá llevar alimentos a sus hijos
de la costa Oriental del Lago nos
trasladamos a Paraguay por llegando a la
frontera con Colombia la población
venezolana fronteriza prefiere vender
material ferroso en el vecino país por
cercanía mayor ganancia y menos riesgo
aquí conocemos a este hombre a quien le
llamaremos José para proteger su
identidad recoge y comercializa chatarra
en maicao son 18 kilómetros en moto
hasta Maracaibo serían 117 aquí llegó a
la raya
agarro la trocha y ya lo vende
colombiana es más trabajo más trabajo
por aquí no hay donde lo compre
y vais para Maracaibo Imagínate cuando
te va a quitar la guardia aquí para allá
va a decir que mantener estratégico y es
malo que demora unos presos lo que le va
a daño que lo que vamos a hacer
sin embargo para que el viaje sea
provechoso debe recoger cierto peso en
mercancía yo tengo que llevar
250 kilos para que para que quede
alguien sé que hay que pagar gasto hay
que pagar portones comida
Aquí van como 190 kilos aquí no van muy
mucha la ganancia que digan esta vez no
logro reunir lo suficiente que tiene
como meta Pero encontró algo de chatarra
que realmente le dejará dividendos y que
no puede vender del lado venezolano
porque iría a la cárcel
Entonces
por esto voy a agarrar la guardia Y si
quiere me mete para ahí me pone cinco o
diez kilos si le da la gana ya es el
procedimiento me pasan para fiscalía
y un poco tiempo presente
empieza su recorrido hasta Colombia es
una carretera que conoce perfectamente
porque la transita cada semana por el
material que lleva debe tratar de evadir
la mayoría de puntos de control de
policías y militares
una vez en paraguaychón atraviesa la
frontera por pasos prohibidos luego de
lidiar con la carga por el camino
fangoso llega al lugar donde le
comprarán la mercancía
todo el material que trae se pesa el
destino será otro estado de Colombia
donde se funde
la carga pesada le dio algo de dinero
pero la ganancia real la obtuvo del
Cobre que trajo escondido
material fino Cómo se encuentran
ya esto
ganó más en ese poquitico que en lo que
trae el pesado rementándome la próxima
pero es difícil para ti conseguirlo
arriesgado pero pone el alimento en
muchas mesas de familias venezolanas
y seguirá siendo así mientras la
chatarra se mantenga como uno de los
principales productos de exportación de
la nación con más petróleo en el mundo
herminia en el reportaje veíamos que
buena parte de la chatarra sale del
desmantelamiento de la industria
petrolera de donde más se obtienen estos
desechos ferrosos para ser exportados sí
Paula uno de los sectores más afectados
Además del petrolero es el de las
telecomunicaciones básicamente antenas y
redes de fibra óptica que son
frecuentemente objeto de vandalismo
también está el complejo siderúrgico de
guayana que se encuentra en ruinas por
falta de mantenimiento la empresa sidor
por ejemplo se ha intentado reactivar
pero muchos de sus componentes que no se
pueden recuperar se han vendido como
chatarra tampoco hay que dejar por fuera
las Industrias privadas que dejaron de
funcionar por la crisis económica debido
al abandono sufrieron desmantelamiento
de parte de personas de clases populares
para venderlas por comida como vimos en
el reportaje termina Muchísimas gracias
muchas gracias Paula y a ustedes los
invito a seguir toda nuestra
programación en France 24 y France
24.com
vuelvo a repetir este y otros episodios
de reporteros
[Música]